at the center of almost every large
Galaxy lies a supermassive black hole
millions or billions of times the mass
of the sun
when two galaxies merge their black
holes enter a dance spiraling inward
toward an eventual Collision
as such massive objects move they bend
the very fabric of the universe
generating gravitational waves
like dropping a rock into a pond these
waves Ripple outward but instead of
producing Peaks and valleys on the
surface of the water gravitational waves
deform space and time
in 2017 scientists detected
gravitational waves that passed through
two detectors with laser arms four
kilometers long
the ripples in space-time change the way
the laser beams overlapped which was
picked up by a super sensitive detector
despite the impressive Precision of this
device it's only able to pick up the
types of ripples that come from the
mergers of small black holes or neutron
stars
to detect gravitational waves from much
heavier black holes like the ones that
anchor galaxies they would need laser
arms too large to even fit on Earth
instead astronomers have come up with a
clever workaround by turning dozens of
dead stars called pulsars into a giant
Laboratory
pulsars are rapidly rotating neutron
stars that shoot out beams of radiation
from their magnetic poles
as the Pulsar spins those beams flash
toward Earth like a lighthouse
some pulsars revolve a few hundred times
per second
the sweeping beam arrives with
Incredible regularity making each Pulsar
like a precise metronome in space
astronomers have been monitoring dozens
of these pulsars in different directions
to help search for gravitational waves
they call these networks Pulsar timing
arrays
the idea is that when gravitational
waves from merging supermassive black
holes pass by these lighthouses they
change the distance between the pulsars
and Earth
some get a tiny bit closer and others
get a little farther from us
that means their rhythmic flashes appear
to get a little faster or slower
the pulsars ACT much like the laser arms
on the ground the difference between
when we expect the flashes to arrive and
when they are actually detected is the
signal of gravitational waves
because the pulsars are so distant the
light has to travel much farther than it
does in the lasers
that means this method should be
sensitive to gravitational waves with
longer wavelengths like those from
supermassive black holes
identifying a specific black hole pair
with this technique is really difficult
so the first objective is to find the
background hum of all the supermassive
black holes combined the so-called
gravitational wave background
in January 2021 scientists announced the
first evidence for such a hum but they
haven't been able to prove it's actually
from the gravitational wave background
several Pulsar timing arrays are
currently hunting for a Telltale pattern
in the hum that would allow them to
claim their detection
if the search proves successful Nature's
lighthouses could help illuminate some
of the darkest most mysterious objects
in the cosmos
foreign